edgar what are you doing
you're browsing the internet unprotected
oh my god
bro how many times i gotta tell you you
gotta download nordvpn wi-fi
with nordvpn all your internet data stay
safe behind the wall of next generation
encryption next generation
you will be the last generation sorry
what about logs there's a strict no logs
policy
they don't track collect anything don't
worry with more vpn you will be safe
it would be as for a child get access to
the actual world wide web hundreds of
streaming services worldwide bam i'm in
japan watching anime boom i'm in india
watching
watching everything except lasagna
you can use on multiple devices as well
you can use it on your phone on your
computer it's easy as a one clickity
clack and they let you connect up to six
devices edgar's gotten tired now time to
wrap up if you go to nordvpn.com
pewdiepie with the link in the
description you get a huge bonus so take
advantage of that because you also get
for additional months for free so use
the link in the description while you
sign up to take advantage for me a vpn
is a must when i'm doing banking on
another wi-fi network or if i want to
watch shows from different countries
it's always there and it's super easy to
use so i recommend it nordvpn.com
thank you for sponsoring this video
let's get on with it ken felix have you
ever thought about serious
hardcore
body transformation surgery
yes i really thought about getting like
like another arm like connected to like
oh yeah back here because there's that
one spot i can't really reach it's like
right in the center and i just can't get
it but if i had an extra arm i could pat
myself in the back and scratch that spot
that's pretty good i would get two heads
so i can shoot two videos at the same
time
that's that's optimization right there
i am actually
[Music]
anyway today we're looking at people
getting leg lengthening
wow which i would never do well you need
legs first
you know
true don't have theirs
[Laughter]
me either i'm just a torso and up have
you ever showed your legs
no i'm not even i'm not even on wiki
feet they don't even get my stuff
all right so if we were about to get leg
lengthening surgery this is what it
looks like let's check it out the
surgery done and now i'm five seven
potentially devastating complications it
is kind of creepy you're breaking both
of your femurs to where i did broke both
of my peoples to get this surgery so i
basically have just two sticks of bone
you break your femurs is that the fat
legs yeah it is it's the fat leg
they break your femurs
oh
i want to see this
[Laughter]
we have to be very careful about
what we do and how it's done i think you
have to do it in india like it's illegal
don't feel like you break your bone and
like the bone marrow whatever like
you eat like a lot of diseases and stuff
can't you yeah but it's worth it dude
going from a beta to a sigma man i'm a
heat shoot you go from 5 11 to 6 foot
man
so tall
if you say you're six foot like no one's
gonna know it doesn't matter
anyway not that i would do that that's
a wild stupid that you're doing
but if it's gonna make you happier in
the long run
then it's worth it
it's a wild thing to do
it's called growing pains
i guess so well i think they set how
much they uh separate the bones before
they like grow together anyway we'll
we'll see i don't know i'm fascinated
wow
i'm disturbed i think i'm probably tall
dude a few inches taller beta look how
short
magnifique what is this the hell is this
countless articles linking size and
success
hey when they when they google go back
what did that say is
okay all right we know but bbc have been
googling oh oh my goodness being small
is seen as a big disadvantage
there are real life advantages to being
told i gotta be honest and this is not
just me being average height which i am
by the way not that it matters
i never understand
i remember early like girls saying i
like not like tall guys
right that's the thing you learn when
that's a thing you're like but why they
all look skinny and bony and weird they
look like rattle they look like you do
this something and it starts playing
music you know what i mean
click on the bones yeah am i the only
one no i'm not shaming tall people i
just don't understand the preference i
guess they want a big strong but they're
never strong they just pick a tall guy
what do you mean it makes no sense
mary told me that she doesn't like like
uh like very skinny like overly skinny
guys and that's why she feeds me so much
you know
the ideal body type you should google
eddie hall
oh let's go
let's go
like i want a strong man i'm like
dreamlike that's what the strongest
gonna get right there
but you probably wouldn't guess that
he's like 6'4 or something like that
either
he's freaking tall oh
you think that's tall interesting bro
you're like you're like five eight shut
up what are you we talking about i'm six
foot [ __ ]
you're really having this conversation
with me right now i am not five eight
take that back right now i am like
barely six foot right yeah and i'm way
taller than you i'm bad this is slander
dude why why did where did they get this
[ __ ] number this is [ __ ] barely
taller than martsy is marty's tiny what
are you talking about kidding me
what are you doing i don't know it just
keeps redirecting me
he's like freaking 20 feet
dude i'm getting a whole head ahead of
her plus she's got heels
the whole forehead that's it
this is a joke
it's okay to be short man it's fine i'm
not [ __ ] short
look at that look at that
i am at 180 i'm 160. that's not even 60.
oh yeah how tall is markiplier's haircut
in this photo
really why is that why i got jack so
tall
yeah this is see you mean do you
understand i don't mind but i know i
know what i know okay just to keep
playing because i could do this all day
with you
are you needing like surgery is this
research no i don't think a thousand
pounds it claims to be able to help
patients grow no we're watching this
video again
oh that's good because i don't need that
but whatever
it was blinded by this was he measuring
a soviet doctor treating injured
soldiers returning nice soviet uh
medicine that's the kind of [ __ ] i want
to do
sign me up die
techniques have changed during the last
70 years but many of the principles
remain the same
a hole is drilled into the leg bone
which is very literally broken in two a
metal rod is put inside and held in
place by another do you think they
carotid chop the legs
just
i'm just saying
they probably do i would if i had to
drill in yo you just drill into it and
that's how they break it the last moment
they give them chop it yeah they have to
chop it but someone they don't show it
this rod which is lengthened a little
bit each day extending yeah yeah they
have a rather they lengthen until the
patient reaches their desired height and
their bones are finally allowed to heal
back together
the surgery was once reserved for people
with a serious injury or deformity but
an increasing number of people i think i
think i've had an email about this it
was like increase your length by at
least like three inches or something but
it was just a pill
good joke nice
but do you think they could actually do
this you know
is that how penis surgery works you
break it with a karate chop i don't know
that's what i'm asking you know do you
karate chop it and you get a metal rod
and maybe like a remote control you can
like
you know there will be no surgical
instruments anywhere near that region
for me okay i don't even want to know
what happens no thank you
i am not even googling it don't forget
okay
but i mean it wouldn't make sense right
how has no one figured this out yet how
to lengthen your pp how has no one
figured that out yet well i think they
have i think it has been done it's just
like risky right didn't like uh
was that old rock drummer dude didn't he
have it done or something
no way what and then he like went and
like made a video with pamela anderson
tommy lee yeah didn't tommy tommy lee
had penis surgery he denies it he
definitely he definitely had penis
surgery you should never have to deny
that that means you're guilty he 100
percent tommy lee
images oh god
[Laughter]
it was at least a rumor i don't know if
it's true or not but i heard they like
like they go in like you know behind the
sack like in that area and like dig in
there and
they're not gonna dig anywhere keep
playing available in more than a dozen
countries from germany the us right
germany india south korea turkey greece
italy and even here italy okay
wait they're living in uk why does this
guy look like he has maker stop it as a
five foot seven mountain of a man myself
i can understand that there's anything
wrong with this kind of surgery you know
you're in london ghetto when they when
this guy look at this guy
can you do mate
[Laughter]
does he have like
sunscreen on his nose when he walked
about what is that
it just looks like it explain this to me
why in any uk like whenever they're do
that why do they walk and talk
they're always walking somewhere you're
right they are it's really weird
especially when you notice and they
think it's cool they think it's cool
they're just like look i did this in one
take and we were walking at the same
time
wow it's like my 18th time walking but
we did it
all right
there are people
that get these surgeries done
by doctors who really don't know what
they're doing and like
that's a scary thing you know it's not
who are these doctor taking on projects
that they don't know what they're doing
what the hell how does that even a thing
yeah what you're gonna walk in doctor
will be taller he's like well i've never
judy chopped a leg in my life but yeah
i'll sure i'll stick a rod in your femur
and
drill holes in it whatever i'm sure i
can do it
i feel doing that i feel like i would
definitely do it now that i heard you
say that i would definitely do that if i
was a doctor yeah i'd be like how hard
is it how [ __ ] hard is it easy no
problem i got a metal rod and i
definitely i definitely have that brain
i just realized
i can do that i feel like every youtuber
that's like had a music career of any
kind hey things like that
ah music's easy i can do that to sign
your slap shut up
if you can make a song
monetize your freaking take it down
wrong they're not wrong either for
thinking i can no i will not listen to
this slider what you think it takes
talent
no four months six months after the
surgery you have to really
know what's going on and still be in
contact with your doctor after that so
that you can get the full
benefits and rehabilitation that you
actually wanted i feel like this guy is
just justifying to himself like oh yeah
i did this crazy thing but i had a good
doctor other people have bad doctors
yeah i don't know what he's talking
about he's just talking about how other
doctors are banned it's like this is
completely besides the point you did
something weird okay according to my
research more and more people are
deciding it is worth it
several clinics are performing leg
lengthening operations at five times the
rate they were just ten years ago
people are having it done each year dr
goodyear specializes in lim
reconstruction for people with an injury
or deformity but what i'm interested in
yeah
british eyebrows right there lengthening
procedures they've had abroad how long
can you get the legs do you reckon when
does your femur max out because i'm
gonna look like i'm walking on stilts
like
why don't you just get stilts couldn't
you just replace your femurs with like
metal steamer feet and metal femurs kind
of like uh wolverine and x-men and just
get like oh get some adamantite yeah
yeah yeah hell yeah that'd be sick every
time you go to the airport you start
beeping you're like it's my legs dude
i don't know what you want me to do you
wouldn't even fit through the
the box so you have to walk there you
you just like walk right in there like
what's going on here this is like wait
wait wait is that the same person oh
that'd be sick look at that man leg like
for such serious surgery most people who
i've come across who wanted cosmetic
lengthening
actually
have quite often psychological problems
body dysmorphic disorders yeah no shh
what are you
you gotta have something going on if
you're like i need middle rides in my
legs i'll do anything doctor yeah
he had a condition which meant he
required surgery to straighten his legs
he then opted to have the leg
lengthening procedure at the same time
reassured
go together and it wouldn't affect so
he's like bonus legs bonus length all
right yeah well he's doing the surgery
because he actually had like a problem
that's because he just wanted to be
taller okay
unfortunately he's been dealing with
problems ever since oh so can you
describe what your complications were
yeah okay so really my only complication
was the fact that
my bone separation was happening faster
than my bone growth would happen so
basically my legs have been my bones
have been pulled apart
um at uh
quite a fast rate
but my bone growth wasn't there so
therefore on the x-rays you could sort
of see it sort of like the gap getting
bigger and bigger and bigger
and nothing so basically i just
couldn't you just haven't slowed it down
what yeah that's why i was like what do
they do there's like
like jacking up a car or something like
cricket cricket it's like okay stop my
bones need to grow back yeah okay
two inches tall here it's fun skydiving
if ryan's synthway guitar can deal with
it
it shouldn't be a problem employers
prefer hiring taller men women only want
to date other guys men get leg
lengthening surgery society
why would you do that
how can people do this this is crazy
i really don't get like the uh
focus on like how tall you are as a guy
doesn't matter yeah but you you and i
are not like super short like imagine
you were really sure i am a giant and
you are
sort of average i guess
i'm like an ogre high and you are like a
troll height oh wait
how tall
okay
that means i get the two heads too so i
can shoot the double videos oh
nice
what are you talking about i'll say i
didn't get the whole height thing but
then i was like well you know i don't
have that problem so i guess i wouldn't
right it's like i don't get people doing
no surgery and you never have that i
don't understand people that are like
you know ugly or poor or anything you
know like why
bro just don't be poor just stop being
poor it's not that hard god
dang look at those but the thing is
shouldn't your femurs be like super long
compared to your tibia or cows or
whatever it's called i'm a youtuber not
a doctor i have no idea i like how it
looks like he's bigger
because he took the photo closer
it's like your before and after workout
pictures you know you're before you're
taking like the bad lighting and you
sleep yeah
okay so he gained eight centimeters nice
oh we got testimonials
would you ever get any kind of cosmetic
surgery no no definitely not not like
your nose or anything like that i didn't
i don't i don't particularly like my
nose but i i don't mind it maybe i get
like a hair transplant or something i'm
gonna fix my
my aging hairline i'll never be bald man
it is escaping me it's running away
yeah
i mean you do what you want i've ever
told you about jaw surgery that i had
you know something that it was pretty
intense so as a young as a young man i
had a bit of an underbite like my jaw my
bottom jaw like oh stuck out a little
further the southern inbred
i'm super redneck
it was a little bit because my jaw had
overgrown but my my top my upper teeth
area or whatever just didn't grow like
it was supposed to so the way they fixed
it after i stopped growing and i had you
know my braces and everything was like
lined up and they were ready they
cut around like you know like you got
your gum and like up there where that
kind of meets like the skin of your lip
and comes out
they basically cut all that away pulled
my face back and sawed the top this top
pallet up here sawed it out and moved it
forward
and then
cut my jaw and like a little
thing in it and slid it and then screwed
it together so the the whenever i go to
the dentist's office and i have an x-ray
they're like what the heck has happened
were you in like a car accident are you
okay
oh what i just had my jaw fixed i had to
get it fixed because like my teeth were
like digging in i was having a bunch of
problems like bunch of jaw problems so i
had to get it fixed
okay at the time you could have asked
like can i get a longer jaw you could
have had
you could have been like chin man i
could have had the crimson chin you know
it could have been
just got it what the [ __ ] is the crimson
chin again the crimson chin yeah check
out the crimson chin man oh hell yeah
this could have been you bro
yeah dude it's like
severe deformity that could have been me
maybe this is what i looked like before
i had the surgery
i forgot i had that it's been
15 years or something like that
they had to go back in one time too
because like some of the screws up here
like around my nose came out and they
like pull my lip up again and pull it
out and it was painful ah
that's me that sounds painful wow it was
wild wild times wild times it's like a
20 000 surgery can you believe that
ugh
bro they barely gained anything are you
kidding me look at it 180. getting like
what five centimeters eight centimeters
that doesn't seem our thing i want to be
a giant if i do this i'll go play
basketball after i get this done
yeah
i guess my nose for example like i never
thought it was bad but i remember people
would always tease me about it and i'm
like i don't get it what's the problem
what is wrong with my nose yeah exactly
i'm a beautiful man what are you talking
about i i don't know i don't i generally
don't know what the problem is but i
mean i think it's the same with length
like you do it for other people because
other people tell you that you need to
be a certain way and you don't no one
has to be a certain way just be you man
just be you
don't do it man i guess like i'm on a
little bit of a topic now with because i
did another video where people were
injecting a bunch of in there to get
muscles and oh it's like the oil and
stuff yeah
and it's just
it seems to be way more common about
guys especially wanting to look a
certain way and i think that's a topic
that's rarely brought up you know what
you hear about fema girls like wanting
to look away and how that affects them
mentally which is obviously still a
problem but i never realized this how
much it actually affects uh guys as well
i think i may be haunted my xbox just
turned itself on hello
okay your xbox like leg lengthening
please thank you no it hurt us talking
maybe
okay
anyway
i can't i can't see you bro yeah when
you watch through this you'll see
all right
kevin hart is short and he's successful
handsome and awesome so there you have
it guys thank you for watching this
video check out ken
and check out me and see you next time
bye